(かさかさ...)
(ピュンピュン)
ビヨヨ～ン
デゥウウウン
O☆K☆I☆N☆A☆I
今ですね
後輩の縦面が寝てるんですけども
起きないんですよ
寝まーすっつっても5秒後にもう意識ないし
今ほっぺとかつねったりちょビンタ飛ばしても全く起きない
なのに、
なんか寝言がね俺も寝ぼけてたからちょ何言ってたかわかんないんですけど、
なんかすごい、、わけわかんないこと言うし、
たまにね、おしゃべりすると、返事が返ってきたりするんですよ。
でなんか、寝てる人に話すのがなんかよくないみたいな、
脳みそ的によくないみたいなことを、聞いたんですけど、噂で。
それほんとかどうか俺なんか、わかんなくて,
一応本人の許可をとってやっていいよってことはもういただいているので、
ではいこう(☆キラッ)
(ピュンピュンピュン)
では早速、コミュニケーションしてみたいと思います。
こんにちは
縦面？
自分何歳？
はあ
縦面？
こんにちは
おはよう
(👍)
何歳？
縦面？
ン///
ン？
血液型は何型？
血液型
好きな食べ物は？
女好き？
スー
ハー
逆立ちメガネ
縦面？
将来の夢は？
お金持ち？
縦面？
はい
お母さんの名前は？
つッｗ
縦面目ー開けて？
フッフォッハｗ
ハッハッｗ
え起きてるの？
ハッハッ
アハッハッハッ～
え起きてる？
グーグーーグッｗ
目ーつぶっていいよ
ハッハッ↑ｗ
アッハッｗ
あ～目ー開けて
キャット
フッッもおｗ
パンはパンでも食べられないパンはな～んだ
パン・ポンじゃありません
んねー起きてるの？ほんとは
ね起きてる？
起きてる？
寝てないです？
へーッフン
すごいな、すくえつま
ねもー起き上がれる？
ッスーザン
頑張って、目ー開けて、
えっ頑張れ、目ー開けて
っハッハッハッｗ
っう、目ー開けて
頑張れ！
もーちょっと、もうちょっと、
フフッ
若いってｗｗｗ
わたっちゃｗ
アハハハ
元カノの名前は？
アカリ？ｗ
笑ってなかった？今？
いや
でも寝てるんすよほんとに
なあ縦面
縦面舌だして
べーって
ンッフフｗ
頑張れ、もうちょっと、
もうちょっと
もうちょっと、アッハハｗ
もうちょい
これくらいが限界ぽいっすね
戻していいよ
イーして、イー、イー
イヒッ
イーヒッｗ
ハハッ
イヒッｗ
口閉じて、イー
頑張れ、もうちょっと、
オハッ、もうちょっと
イーってイーｗ
ハーハッハッハッハッｗ
テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テーテテテテーテーテテテテーテテテテーテー
テテテテーテーテテ、テテテテー↓テー↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑、テへペロッ☆
ありがとういい動画が撮れたよ
ワァ！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
へッ
おはよう
デゥンス
オワッ、ハッｗ
寝れた？
はい
ハッハァｗ